Школа у Гранітному - крайньому селі на підконтрольній Києву території на Донеччині,
практично на лінії розмежування. Школа не раз потрапляла під обстріли.
Зараз класні кімнати порожні - щоправда, не через війну, а через коронавірусні обмеження.
Війна ж - це те, з чим місцеві живуть уже вісім років.
Йдемо на роботу, точно так і діти йдуть до школи. І ми не знаємо,
що буде через п'ять хвилин, через 10 хвилин. Ми не знаємо, що буде вночі.
Тому це постійна така тривога, це постійний страх…
Буквально за кілька сотень метрів звідси - остання українська позиція.
Ця школа - на лінії вогню, коли стріляють з іншого боку.
У Гранітному скрізь помітна присутність військових.
Офіційно діє режим припинення вогню, проте іноді вночі чутно обстріли.
Ми вже знаємо, куди хто де стріляє, і вже якось звикли вдома сидіти.
Раніше, звичайно, було гірше. У нас уже місце в підвалі було, якщо що ми бігли у підвал,
захищалися, і такі-от справи були.
Утім, масивне стягування Росією військ уздовж українського кордону
може призвести до чергової ескалації.
Ми купили тут будинок, настала тиша, а зараз невідомо, як буде далі.
За півтори години їзди на авто від Гранітного, у Маріуполі, мешканці
продовжують жити своїм життям - попри можливу загрозу вторгнення.
До найгіршого не готуємося. Мені здається, що все буде добре,
тому що у нас тут ніби багато військових.
Боятися просто, що щось станеться - це напруження, воно збиває.
Ну, от уявіть собі, що всі припинять працювати. Водій тролейбуса не вийде на роботу,
бо він боїться, що війна почнеться. І що, люди не доїдуть на роботу?
Припинять працювати? Тому ми робимо свою справу до моменту,
поки є можливість робити свою справу. Якщо раптом щось трапиться,
то ми будемо адаптуватися в той момент.
Думати на сто відсотків, що все буде добре, звісно, неправильно,
але навіщо думати про погане.
Усі вісім років ситуація так само напружена. Можливо, зараз черговий пік,
але нічого нового за вісім років.
Люди на сході України звикли до війни і не панікують.
Натомість скупчення російських військ на кордоні з Україною
змусило багатьох європейців прокинутися і усвідомити реальність небезпеки,
з якою доводиться жити українцям. Багато високопосадовців
з країн Заходу відвідують Київ і навіть прифронтову смугу.
Серед них й очільниця МЗС Німеччини.
Я тут, на місці, аби отримати власне уявлення про те, що це означає,
коли ми в центрі Європи все ще маємо війну, як люди живуть за обставин,
коли не можуть вранці просто відвести своїх дітей у школу, і життя йде собі далі,
натомість знову і знову стаються обстріли, знову і знову трапляються зіткнення,
внаслідок яких є жертви; і передусім побачити, як все ще значно пошкоджена
інфраструктура, а також разом з місією ОБСЄ переконатися на власні очі,
як дотримуються чи не дотримуються режиму припинення вогню
і наскільки терміново нам необхідно нарешті прийти до вирішення цього конфлікту.
Назад до Гранітного. Підконтрольна Україні територія закінчується
за останніми будинками села. За невеличкою річкою - демілітаризована смуга.
Пішохідний місток - єдиний шлях до сусіднього села у так званій "сірій зоні".
Село немале. Люди працюють там, діти ходять до школи.
Одна з тих, кому щодня доводиться перетинати лінію зіткнення, - учителька Людмила.
Вона живе за річкою і не хоче називати своє справжнє ім'я, бо її життя
залежить від хороших відносин з обома сторонами.
У її селі обстріли відбуваються ще частіше.
Є робота, я ходжу на роботу. Так, важко, так буває небезпечно,
дуже небезпечно. Ну, не знаю, не можу, не хочу я просто взяти
кинути роботу і кудись поїхати. Не можу.
Учителька каже, що все ще не втратила останню надію,
що російсько-український конфлікт вдасться вирішити мирно.